bonsoir alexis la sécurité donc un enjeu
grandes licences de 2022 oui clairement
ce qui vient d'être dit dans ce débat on
voit bien que le thème de la sécurité
alors il revient de manière périodique
avant les grands scrutins comme
l'élection présidentielle mais là on
voit bien que depuis vingt ans le
chiffre se dégradent celle de la
violence du quotidien
malgré les chantiers ouverts par abel
macron sur les violences domestiques
aussi des chiffres sont mauvais on voit
que partout il y a ce terme qu'on avait
du mal à accepter eric dupond moretti
qui ne voulaient pas le voir
l'ensauvagement parce que trop connoté à
l'extrême droite mais la réalité est là
on voit maintenant davantage de violence
davantage aussi de degré de violence
avec ces dealers a remis des armes qui
circulent partout sur le territoire
rappelez-vous l'épisode tchétchènes à
dijon où on voyait ses vidéos de gang
puisqu'il est question de deux gangs la
de mafieux qui qui sortait un arsenal
militaire avec le maire de dijon
françois rebsamen qui lui disait n'avoir
pas vu d'armes sur les vidéos donc il ya
un déni de la classe politique par
rapport à une réalité que les policiers
voient bien eu sur le terrain ou que les
services de renseignement également
j'espère revois aussi et cette
prolifération finalement de la violence
fait qu'elle touche tout le monde et
c'est pas une question d'insécurité
ressenti c'est une insécurité réelle et
elle devient évidemment une
préoccupation majeure
mais le politique a bien du mal à y
répondre on le voit que fait gérald
darmanin il prend l'avion dans la nuit
pour aller avignon présenté ses
condoléances
mais où est le plan où est le courage
politique il sort une déclaration disant
que c'est la guerre un fait aux dealers
mais en réalité cette guerre elle manque
de moyens comme la guerre que disait
emmanuel macron faite aux virus ou les
soignants n'avaient pas d'équipement
c'est la même chose pour les policiers
qui manquent de moyens qui le disent
depuis longtemps je veux dire les
syndicats de police
on fait grève bien avant et le
mécontentement est partout c'est une
profession se suscite beaucoup également
le mal est très présent dans beaucoup de
commissariat avec en plus bien sûr une
image dégradée avec ce qui s'est passé
lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
avec les nombreux blessés et la façon
dont on t'a est utilisée là aussi la
force par le pouvoir politique de ce qui
manque aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une
volonté politique claire et qui ne soit
pas une volonté simplement de faire
campagne ce que fait mal macro
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il prépare
finalement ce thème de l'insécurité pour
mais on voit bien que il a du mal à
allah se positionner c'est un thème
qu'il avait totalement oublié dans sa
campagne de 2017 et avec la mort
justement de ce policier en exercice est
ce que le risque de la goutte d'eau
notamment ou encore les syndicats de
police existe bel et bien
pâques les syndicats je crois que tous
les policiers en ont plus qu'assez
d'être des cibles il y a eu cette
policière administrative égorgé lors
d'un attentat islamiste à rambouillet
c'était il ya quinze jours
l'émotion était était partout palpable
hélas ce jeune père de famille 36 ans
deux enfants qui faisait son métier et
qui se fait descendre froidement par un
dealer qui arrive à prendre la fuite
était chaque semaine on a aussi ses
nouvelles de guet-apens dans certains
quartiers où policiers et pompiers sont
pris pour cible donc systématiquement
évidemment c'est une profession qui en a
vraiment marre de tout tout le poids
finalement de la république repose sur
ses épaules puisque on voit bien que le
maquereau on s'est beaucoup appuyé sur
eux pour gérer les crises sociales or
c'est pas avec des policiers qu'on gère
des crises sociales c'est avec des vrais
débats c'est avec des moyens les
policiers sont là pour protéger les
populations et aussi être capable de se
protéger mais encore une fois manque de
matériel manque de moyens alors il ya
quelques investissements
il ya des annonces qui sont faites mais
elles arrivent tardivement et on voit
par exemple la loi sécurité globale et
une loi qui va faire monter les polices
privées plutôt que de donner des moyens
à la police nationale et qui va faire
aussi en sorte que les polices
municipales bricole
mais plus de prérogatives sans pour
autant les doter de plus de moyens donc
on est en train finalement il ya un
double discours celui de dire qu' on est
en guerre contre les points de deal
points de deal qui sont connus à avignon
le points de deal où le drame s'est
passé hier est répertorié donc c'est à
dire que la guerre est c'est-à-dire beau
d'utiliser cette terminologie là mais
c'est faux si on veut s'attaquer au
trafic de drogue on s'attaque aux mafias
on s'attaque à l'entrée de la drogue sur
le territoire national et on s'attaque
aux gros bonnets pas au point de did
là on est en train de faire de la
communication politique ça commence à se
voir et je crois que le ras-le-bol est
complet on voit bien qu'il ya des
tentatives aussi de dire bon bah puisque
l'état est incapable avec cette équipe
actuelle l'appel des généraux de dire
nous allons nous en occuper
et je crois que dans la police c'est un
peu pareil de dire mais si le politique
est à ce point lâche et ne peut pas nous
aider à résoudre les problèmes il va
falloir se débrouiller nous mêmes mais
évidemment impossible on voit bien que
la tentation est grande de séparatisme
au sein de ces professions avec en plus
le en même temps ma chronique qui fait
que vous avez d'un côté gérald darmanin
à l'intérieur qui a ce discours martial
qui soutient ses troupes d'une certaine
façon les de l'autre côté eric dupond
moretti qui lui refuse de dire que la
france est un beau groupe georges et qui
fait en sorte que la justice est la
deuxième jambe qui fonctionne mal
puisque on a du mal à faire appliquer
les peines qu'au manque de places de
prison et que là encore la justice ne
manque de moyens comme tout le reste
d'ailleurs des administrations
régaliennes
donc c'est encore une fois en même temps
difficile à comprendre rapidement alexis
qu'elle peut être du coup la stratégie
du gouvernement
la stratégie du gouvernement elle est
donc d'un côté plus de mesures de court
terme vers un état policier
c'est le risque à mesure de surveillance
la sécurité globale mais aussi le mois
contre le séparatisme des moyens à la
police
et puis l'autre côté c'est la
communication politique c'est ce que
sait faire emmanuel macron le mieux donc
préparer la campagne de 2022 sur ce
sujet donc allumer des chiffres allumez
les petits voyants et dire qu'il est
présent partout
c'est ce que faire gerald dharmanand le
problème c'est que ces stratégies doit
s'appuyer sur le ministre de l'intérieur
et gérald darmanin a des ambitions ça va
être pour lui évidemment
important de gérer cette crise aussi
avec succès et de donner les moyens et
un tremplin pour une future carrière
parce que je pense que gérald darmanin
ne souhaite pas s'arrêter là et de
l'autre côté c'est une stratégie qui
finalement bénéficie à 100% au
rassemblement national qui n'a pas bougé
de ses fondamentaux de dire que le
problème en france c'est l'insécurité et
l'immigration et sans avoir à faire de
campagne au discours tout simplement
l'impression que les faits donnent
raison à marine le pen et qu'elle peut
tout à fait gagnée avec d'ailleurs la
crise des républicains qui va encore
accélérer je pense la recomposition à
droite en sa faveur
et ça c'est évidemment ce que veut
éviter à tout prix l alma kron parce
qu'ils seraient en faiblesse s'ils
n'arrivaient pas lui à récupérer les
électeurs de droite pour le relancer sa
campagne pour 2022 merci alexis poulain